françois show man si général de brigade
expert en géostratégie bonjour merci de
répondre aux questions et d'analysé avec
nous ce sommet une première question sur
ce qui à l'agenda à l'ordre du jour
françoise souvent si c'est la stabilité
stratégique dmitri termine le directeur
du centre d'analysé carnegie de moscou a
déclaré
ni la russie ni les états unis ne
veulent qu'une guerre nucléaire comment
se mettre d'accord
déjà ce qu'un délit de ta journée
d'ailleurs c'est que dès lors on peut se
rencontrer et discuter ce genre de
problème peut être traitée au moins dans
les grandes lignes
l'objectif est bien d'éviter de conflits
maintenant parler d'un conflit nucléaire
je dirais que je suis un peu surpris
qu'on évoque encore cette possibilité
aujourd'hui malgré filmant la présence
de nombreuses armes nucléaires je n'ai
pas entendu dire de qui que ce soit
aujourd'hui au niveau des états que on
allait vers une guerre nucléaire sous
quelque forme que ce soit donc je trouve
que c'était papale un peu alarmiste dans
un contexte où nous avons deux états
puissants qui sont la russie les états
unis avec des personnes responsables à
leur tête qui sont monde est bien
éloigné de toute question sur la guerre
nucléaire potentielle entre ces états
voilà donc pense que c'est très
alarmiste et n'a pas beaucoup de sens
en revanche que l'on aille peut-être
vers un meilleur désarmement des armes
nucléaires y est mais a rapporté sortie
de du sipri disant notamment qu'il y
avait une légère sur dotation d'un
nucléaire l'a peut-être relancé pour les
new start qui a eu qui ont eu lieu qui
rappelle la limitation des têtes
nucléaires même aller plus loin dans le
désarmement nucléaire ne semblerait pas
totalement stupide dans le cas de ceux
qui de discussion benji sera pas le cas
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas en tous les
cas à l'agenda françois souvent si cet
après-midi la cybercriminalité
washington accuse régulièrement moscou
d'être à l'origine d'attaqués
informatiques sur son sol alors
qu'aucune preuve n'a été avancé par les
autorités américaines des accusations
antirusse qualifier je cite deux gros
tests par le chef du kremlin c'était
hier matin sur la chaîne américaine nbc
maxime hébert nous avons été accusé de
toutes sortes de choses d'ingérence dans
les élections de cyberattaques et pas
une seule fois
pas une seule fois ils n'ont pris la
peine de produire la moindre preuve
juste des accusations sans fondement
face aux accusations de cyber attaques
la réponse de vladimir poutine est clair
depuis plusieurs mois les états unis
accuse la russie de violation de son
cyberespace la plus importante en date
celle menée en mars dernier contre
solarwinds une entreprise spécialisée
dans la gestion de réseaux informatiques
des victimes entreprises et
administrations à 80% américaine est un
coupable tout désigné un adversaire
probablement d'origine russe est
responsable de la plupart des intrusions
récemment découvertes dans des réseaux
informatiques gouvernementaux et non
gouvernementaux
il s'agissait d'une entreprise de grande
envergure et je crois que nous pouvons
maintenant dire assez clairement que ce
sont les russes qui étaient engagés dans
cette activité
pourtant derrière ces accusations
hâtives aucune preuve formelle
même parmi la classe politique
américaine cet avis n'est pas partagé
par tout le monde
la russie la russie la russie quoi qu'il
se produise c'est toujours la même
rengaine que nous servent les médias de
masse ce pourrait être l'oeuvre de la
chine il est regrettable qu'il ait fallu
plus de trois semaines pour finalement
publié une accusation vague
j'espère que nous aurons bientôt quelque
chose de plus catégorique un état
étranger patients sophistiqué et bien
financée est probablement derrière cette
attaque
mais quand vous désigner quelqu'un vous
devez en être certain c'est comme un
acte de guerre
plusieurs cyber-attaques ont depuis
toucher les etats-unis avec à chaque
fois moscou dans le viseur récemment un
oléoduc responsable de
l'approvisionnement de la côte est des
états unis en carburant a dû fermé ses
vannes après une attaque informatique
le principal suspect dark side un groupe
de cybercriminels qui se définit comme
apolitique et guidés par l'argent
pourtant encore là les autorités
américaines sus
le kremlin d'en être à l'origine même si
joe biden en personne affirmé à cette
occasion ne détenir aucune preuve d'une
implication russe cybercriminalité mais
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure
françois chauvancy également le
désarmement on peut rappeler
dernièrement le traité est fait ni sur
les forces nucléaires de portée
intermédiaire traiter définitivement
clos le traité ciel ouvert
définitivement clos puisque là la
semaine dernière la russie s'en est
désengagé avant cela c'était les états
unis qui s'en était désengagé le traité
new start vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure qui a été prolongé au début de
l'année
ça fait beaucoup de questions sur le
front de la stabilité stratégique
sachant qu'il y a eu un sommet du g7 le
week end dernier en angleterre et les
pays du g7 ont évoqué le site le front
commun face à la chine
et face à la russie que va répondre
vladimir poutine selon vous par rapport
à ces sujets de stabilité stratégique
je pense qu'il va s'efforcer sans doute
de rassurer je dirais les occidentaux
pour prendre un terme générique donc
rassurer les occidentaux mais sans
baisser la garde
la russie aujourd'hui est dans une
position que personnellement je conserve
de forces à la une capacité de nuisance
si elle n'obtient pas ce qu'elle espère
dans différentes négociations
ça me choque pas outre mesure 1 c'est le
jeu de la géopolitique donc ça me semble
très normal donc maintenant la stabilité
nécessaire mais il ya des zones quand
même de conflit vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure d'une embase de l'ukraine c'est
un sujet on parle aussi du moyen-orient
les forces militaires russes sont
appliqués à plus ou moins grande échelle
les occidentaux si je reconnais dans
cette recherche d'une paix et d'une
stabilité et et puis peut-être une chose
qui me semblent importantes c'est la
prévisibilité
aujourd'hui le président poutine est
capable par sa seule autorité de
les actions peut-être déstabilise
déstabilisante notamment pour les autres
pays et que peut-être si la russie était
plus prévisible et les traités sont
faits pour ça normalement ce serait
peut-être une bonne chose ça ne veut pas
dire que le geste doit être unilatérale
ça veut dire que chacun doit y mettre du
sien pour trouver une solution de
prévisibilité
il ya une déclaration juste avant ce
sommet en fin de matinée aux alentours
de la mi journée celle de dmitri peskov
le porte parole du kremlin le porte
parole de vladimir poutine il a dit le
sommet etats unis russie ne peut pas
être historique on doit attendre
on doit attendre aucune percée ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire qu'au final ce
sommet va accoucher d'une souris c'est
ça non je crois que nous sommes dans un
processus de remise en état des
relations diplomatiques il faut pas
entrer dans le jeu des grandes décisions
des grandes orientations déjà nous avons
deux présidents qui se parlent alors que
deux pays ne se parlaient plus depuis
bien longtemps
le fait de se parler même si on n'est
pas d'accord c'est important c'est
mettre sur la table et je crois que
c'est ce qu'a dit joe biden on met sur
la table nos problèmes l'un et l'autre
ont dit que je les mettais lignes rouges
sur la table voilà 2000 nourri une
grande mutuelle notamment en pariant sur
le temps et l'ouverture de l'ukraine à
l'otan
poutine a été très clair sur la question
joe bagel miss et les droits de l'homme
pour de part et d'autre effectivement il
ya des nids rouge donc se parler c'est
bien se rencontrer c'est mieux à temps
devant décision aujourd'hui c'est
prématuré
si les choses se fassent à peu près bien
aujourd'hui dans les mois qui viennent
sans doute qu'il y aura des
améliorations positives dans ses
relations entre les deux états merci
françois chavance y est d'avoir répondu
à toutes nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes général de brigade et expert
en géostratégie